the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
all right everyone let's get started
so all right good afternoon so this is
the third lecture of six triple one and
600 as always please download slides and
code to follow along so quick recap of
what we did last time last time we
talked about strings as a new object
type as sequences of characters and then
we introduced two new concepts that
allowed us to write slightly more
complicated programs so we introduced
branching with these keywords
if/elif/else and branching allowed us to
write programs that us as programmers
could could introduce decisions into our
programs and then we introduced two
different kinds of loops while loops and
for loops and those also added a little
bit of complexity to our programs today
we're going to talk a little bit more
about strings so we're going to see a
couple more operations that you can do
on strings and string objects and then
we're going to talk about three
different algorithms I guess and check
algorithm an approximate solution
algorithm and a bisection method
algorithm okay so let's dive right in
we'll talk a little bit about strings
first so strings we thought of them as
sequences of characters right
case-sensitive as we saw in in in
programs we wrote last lecture and
strings are objects and we can do all of
these operations on string objects like
tests if they're equal less than greater
than and so on turns out we can do more
than just concatenate two strings
together or do these little tests on
them so we're going to start introducing
the the idea of of a function or
procedure and we're going to see more
about functions and how you can write
your own functions next lecture but for
today you can think of a function as
sort of a procedure that does something
for you okay someone already wrote this
so the first one we're going to look at
is a pretty popular function and when
applied on a string this function called
Len will tell you the length of a string
so that's going to tell you how many
characters are in the string
and characters are going to be letters
digits special characters spaces and so
on so it's just going to count how many
letters how many how many characters in
their string so if I of the string s is
equal to ABC remember string is in
quotation marks then if I do this this
if I write this expression Len s here
since it's an expression it has a value
so it evaluates to a certain value and
by definition it's going to tell me what
the length of the string is which is
three characters long okay another thing
that we can do on strings is since their
sequence of characters I might want to
get what character is at a certain
position so we do this using this fancy
word called indexing but pretty much
what indexing into a string means is
you're going to tell Python I want to
know the character at this certain
position or at this certain index inside
my string okay so once again let's use
this string s is equal to ABC and let's
index into it so in computer science we
start from 0 counting by convention
notice we had a problem set 0 in this
class
Python is no different so python and
python you start indexing at position 0
or you start indexing at 0 so the first
character in your string we say is at
position 0 so right or at index 0 the
next character in the string is at index
1 and the next character in the string
is at index 2 in Python it turns out you
can also use negative numbers to index
and if you use if you index into the
string with negative 1 for example that
means that you want the last character
in the string so the last character in
your string is always going to be at
position negative 1 second the last
character is at negative 2 third to last
characters at negative 3 and so on and
so on ok so the way you index into a
string is with these square brackets
here
and this is the notation so if I want
the character at position 0 or at index
0 I say s which is the string I want to
index into and then inside the square
brackets I say what index I want so s at
index 0 is going to be the value a s at
index 1 is going to be the value B and
so on and so on and we can also do
negative negative indexing as well if
you do try I added this in here if you
do try to index into a string beyond the
limits of the string and we can even try
this out just to show you that it's not
the end of the world if we do that if we
have s is equal to ABC and we have s at
position 20 for example obviously my
string is only length 3 so what's at
position 20 I get an error right I call
this angry text here in Python but
really the most relevant thing to note
is these last couple of lines here this
tells you what line is problematic so s
at position 20 has an issue and this
last line here tells me what actual
error I have so it's an index error
which means I'm trying to index too far
into the string because it only has
three characters okay so it's nice to be
able to get a single character out of my
string but sometimes I might want to get
a substring so I want to start at you
know the first character and go halfway
into the string or I want to take the
few few characters in between or I want
to skip every other letter or something
like that in my string so if I want to
do this slightly more complicated
interaction with strings we call that
slicing slicing into a string okay and
this notation here should seem a little
bit familiar because we saw it last
lecture when we did it with a range okay
we had a start stop and a step the
notation was a little bit different
because in range we had open close
parenthesis
seas and commas in between but except
for that this sort of works the same the
start is the index starting from zero
from where you want to slice into the
string the stop is the stop index you're
going to go up until stop minus one and
take that index and then the step is
every how many letters you wish to take
so this is the full notation here but
sometimes you can not give it a third a
third sort of number in here so if you
only give it two numbers then that to
Python that represents just the start
and the stop and by default step is
going to be one and there's a lot of
other things you can do with with
strings you can just you can omit
numbers and just leave colons and Python
just by the way that by by definition
the way that whoever wrote slicing had
decided if you omit numbers then it's
going to be equivalent to these things
here so we slice using square brackets
just like indexing except now that we
can get now we can give it two numbers
okay so with this string s if we slice
into the if we slice into the string s
we start from index 3 and go up and up
until index 6 so if we have a b c d e f
g h right this is position 0 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 and you just you just count so s
starting from 3 and going till 6 is
going to start here 3 right so it's
going to come up with sorry d and then
we're going to take e and then we're
going to take f and since we're going
until stop minus 1 we're not going to
take g right because this is position 6
and we're going until 6 minus 1
okay the next one here three six two is
going every other one right so we start
at 3 and then we skip every other one so
we go D but not E and then F and then
stop if you do s and then nothing
nothing inside except colons notice that
you're going to have s and then nothing
and then :
nothing : nothing so nothing for start
nothing for stop nothing for step and
that's just going to evaluate to the
string itself it's the same as 0 to the
length s going every step this one might
actually be useful it reverses the
string automatically for you so with
this one little line here you can get
the inverse of your string and that's
equivalent to that so the minus 1
represents starting from the end and
going back every letter and then this
one's a little bit more more complicated
but also not too bad okay okay so as
we're doing with the as word as we're
doing these string slices again if
you're unsure what something does just
type it into spider and you know you
might be surprised you might not be but
it's a good way to check yourself to
make sure you know you're understanding
what's happening okay one thing I want
to mention and it's good to keep this in
the back of your mind we're going to
come back to this as we as we start
talking about slightly more complicated
object types but strings are immutable
so just keep this word in the back of
your mind as we go through this class
and what I mean by this is that an
actual string object once it's created
cannot be modified okay this might not
mean anything right now but let me just
draw a little something let's say I have
this string s is equal to hello remember
in the first lecture we drew a diagram
sort of like this this is my memory I
have this object hello and this object
hello is bound to this variable s right
so now I can access the object hello
using this variable s now you might
think well since I could index into a
string I might be able to you know just
say something like s at position zero is
equal to Y right and that'll just change
the little H into a Y and I'll have an
object
well strings are immutable which means
in Python you're not actually allowed to
do this and it gives you an error if you
do try to do that if you want the
variable s to point to the string ye ll
oh you could just say s is equal to Y ll
o or you could do string operations like
this and this takes the Y and it
concatenates it to the string s all of
the elements starting from position 1
which is e ll o so this makes ye ll o
now internally what happens when I when
I write this line is Python says ok I'm
going to break my bond with this
original object hello I'm going to bind
my string variable s to the new object
yellow and this other old object still
is in memory somewhere but it's an
entirely different object that I've
created here again might not mean
anything right now but just keep this in
the back of your mind strings are
immutable ok all right so the next thing
I want to talk about is a little bit of
recap of on for loops and we're going to
see how we can apply for loops very
easily too right very nice readable code
when dealing with strings ok so remember
that for loops had a loop variable right
my loop variable being this var here in
this particular case it could be
anything you want and it's variable in
this particular case iterates iterates
over this sequence of numbers 0 1 2 3 4
so the very first time through the loop
var has a value of 0 it does the
expressions in the loop as soon as
they're done var takes the value 1 it
does all the expressions in the loop and
then var takes the value 2 and it does
all the way up until 0 1 2 and the last
time it goes around is with var is equal
to 3 and remember we said that we can
customize our range in order to start
from a custom value to end at a
different value and to skip certain
numbers so so far we've only been using
for loops over a sequence of numbers but
actually for loops are a lot more
powerful than that you can use them to
iterate over any sequence of values not
just numbers but also strings ok so here
are two pieces of code this one and this
one here ok these two pieces of code
both do the exact same thing okay to me
possibly to you this one looks a lot
more readable than this one right just
at a first glance a farmer to read this
one just using the keywords and and and
variables here it's out it would sound
like broken English right but you you
could decipher what I'm trying to say
for a char in a string s if the char is
equal to I or a char is equal to you
print there is an i or you okay
sounds weird but you could probably tell
what I was trying to do here whereas up
here it's it's a little more complicated
to tell what I'm doing right you have to
sort of think about it a little bit for
some index in this range of numbers 0
through the length of the of the string
s if s at position index is an i or s at
position index is a you print there's an
ir you okay
both of these codes just go through the
string s and if it encounters a letter
that's an i or you it's just going to
print out this string here but this
bottom one is a lot more pythonic it's
an actual word created by the Python
community and it just looks pretty right
like you can you can tell what it what
this codes supposed to do whereas this
one is a little bit harder to decipher
so that's sort of an illustration of a
for loop over a sequence of characters
right so char is going to be a loop
variable still and the loop variable
instead of getting instead of iterating
over a set of numbers it's going to
iterate over every character in s
directly and char is going to be a
specific character right it's going to
be a letter okay so here's a more
complicated example I wrote this code Oh
a couple years ago and it was my attempt
at creating robot cheerleaders because I
needed some motivation and and then yeah
I googled last night robot cheerleaders
and was not disappointed created this
jiff looks pretty cool and it looks like
they kind of stole my idea but that's
fine so let's look at what this codes
supposed to do I'm gonna run it okay I'm
gonna run it and then we'll go through
it okay so all right it prints out I
will cheer for you enter a word you know
what I like robots so I'll put in robots
how enthusiastic and my about robots
let's say six okay so what this is going
to print is it's a cheerleader right
give me an R R give me an O o give me a
B B and so on and so on what does that
spell robots and it's going to print it
six times because I'm six out of ten
enthusiastic about robots okay so that's
pretty much what that codes supposed to
do and you can write it using what we've
learned so far now let's go through it a
little bit and I'm going to show you
just how how easy it is to convert this
code using a for loop over characters
right right now what it does is it asks
the user for input so a word and a
number and then it does this thing here
right first it uses a while loop
and second it uses indexing okay and the
tip here that what tips you off that
it's using indexing is right it's using
the square bracket here into the word
okay
and obviously it's using a while loop
and it has to first create a counter
initialize it and then down here it's
going to increment it inside the while
loop if you remember that's sort of what
we need to do for a while loops so it's
going to start at zero and it's just
basically going to go through index I is
equal to 0 1 2 3 4 which is going to go
all the way to the end of the word
whatever the user typed in in this case
robots it's going to get the character
at that position right word at position
I is going to be a character this line
here is just sort of for pretty for for
the cheerleading to make sense it's just
to take care of letters that make sense
to use on right so give me a B give me
unbe so give me unbe does not make sense
right so that's just taking care of that
and I'm using this in keyword to check
whether the character so the character
are for example in robots is inside on
letters and unlettered I've defined up
here which is these are all the letters
that make sense to put an
and so if it makes sense to use on
before the letter use that and otherwise
use just an a and after I'm done I say
what is that spell and then it's just a
for loop that goes times many times and
prints out the word and the exclamation
mark so okay so this code might have
been a little bit more intuitive if I
rewrote it or if I'd originally wrote
written it with a for loop okay so this
part here right the while loop and
indexing and creating my original
counter we can get rid of that and we
can replace it with this for char in
word okay
I'm originally using char so I can use
char as my loop variable again and
simply I'm just going to iterate over
the word itself so now instead of having
this mess here I have one liner that
says for every character in my word do
all this stuff here so that remains the
same and then I don't even need to
increment a counter variable because I'm
not using wild loops anymore I'm just
using a for loop okay so the code
becomes delete that for char in word and
then delete that and that does the exact
same thing okay and it's a lot more
readable right all right so this was our
toolbox at the beginning of this course
we are two and a half
I guess lectures in these are the things
we've added to it
we know integers float floats boolean's
we know a bit of string manipulation
math operations we added recently these
conditionals and branching right to
write slightly more interesting programs
and now we have loops for and while
loops to add interesting and more
complicated programs okay so with these
the second part of this lecture is going
to be looking at three different
algorithms okay that's the sort of
computer science part of this of this
class introduction to computer science
and programming using Python
don't let the word algorithms scare you
right there they're not that complicated
you just have to sort of think a little
bit about them and and and you'll be
able to get them okay so we're going to
look at three algorithms all in the
context of solving one problem which is
finding the cube root first algorithm is
guess and check then we're going to look
at an approximation algorithm and then a
bisection search so the first is the
guess and check method okay you might
have done this
in math in high school the guess and
check method is is also sometimes called
exhaustive enumeration and you'll see
why so given a problem let's say find
the cube root of a number let's say you
can guess a starting value for a
solution the guess and check method
works if you're able to check if your
solution is correct
so if your guess is originally zero you
can say is zero cubed equal to the cube
the cube of whatever I'm trying to find
the cube root of so if I'm trying to
find the cube root of eight is zero
cubed equal to eight No
right so the solution is not correct if
it's not correct yes another value do it
systematically until you find a solution
or you've guessed all of the values
possible you know all the possible
values you've exhausted all of your
search space
so here's very simple guess and check
code that finds the cube root of a
number so I'm trying to find the cube
root of eight so my cube is eight I'm
going to have a for loop that says I'm
going to start from zero and I'm going
to go all the way up to so I'm going to
start from zero and go all the way up to
eight for every one of these numbers I'm
going to say is my guess to the power of
three equal to the cube eight and if it
is I'm going to print out this this
message okay pretty simple however this
code is not very user-friendly
right if if the user wants to find the
cube root of nine they're not going to
get any output
okay because we never print anything in
the case of of the the guest not being a
perfect cube or the cube not being a
perfect cube okay so we can modify the
code a little bit to add to extra
features okay the first is we're going
to be able to deal with negative cubes
which is kind of cool and the second is
we're going to tell the user if the cube
is not a perfect cube
hey this cube is not a perfect cube so
we're not going to silently just fail
because then the user has some sort of
feedback on their on their input so
let's step through this code we have
first of all a for loop just like before
and we're going to go through zero to
eight in this case we're using the
absolute value because we might want to
find the cube root of negative numbers
first thing we're doing is doing this
check here instead of guessing if the
instead of guessing whether the guess to
the power of three is equal to the cube
we're going to check if it's greater or
equal to and we're going to do that for
the following reason so if we're if
we're trying to find the cube root of
eight for example like versus a cube
root of nine this is eight and this is
nine okay what does this code going to
do it's going to first guess zero zero
cubed is not greater equal to eight 1
cubed is not greater equal to eight two
cubed is greater equal to eight so here
once we've guessed two we're going to
break because we found a number that
works and there's no need to keep
looking right once we found the perfect
the cubed root of this number eight
there's no need to keep searching write
the remainder three four five six seven
eight okay sort of the same idea when
we're trying to find the cube root of
nine we're going to start with zero zero
to power three
is less than 9 1 ^ 3 is less than 9 2 ^
3 is less and 9 when we get to 3 ^ 3
that's going to be greater than 9 so
this code tells us once we've picked a
number that's beyond the logical sort of
cubes of the what's sorry once we've
picked a number that's beyond the
reasonable number of our cubed root of
our cube the cube root of our cube then
we can we should stop because again it
doesn't make sense to keep searching
because if 3 to the power of 3 is
already greater than 9 4 to the power of
3 is also going to be greater than 9 and
so on okay so once we break here we
either have guess being 2 or guess being
3 depending on what cube we're trying to
find and if the guess to the power of 3
is not equal to the cube then obviously
a cube was not a perfect cube so that's
this case here if we were looking at 3
at the cube root of 9 and otherwise this
part here just looks at whether we
should make it a positive or or a
negative cube okay so if our original
cube was less than 0 then obviously the
cube root of a negative number is going
to be a negative number and otherwise
it's just our word guests okay so that's
the guess and check method slightly more
feature-rich program for guessing the
cube root but that only tells us the
cube root of perfect cubes and doesn't
really give us any anything else any
more information so sometimes you might
want to say well I don't care that 9 is
not a perfect cube just give me a close
enough answer okay
so that's where approximate solutions
come in so this is where we're good
we're okay with having a good enough
solution okay so in order to do that
we're going to start with a guess and
then increment that guess by some small
value okay start from 0 and start
incrementing by point zero zero one and
just go upwards from there and at some
point you might find a good enough
solution
in this program we're going to keep
guessing as long as we're not close
enough and close enough is going to be
given by this epsilon value in the
program okay so as long as the guest
cubed minus the cube so how far away are
we from the actual answer is greater
than some epsilon keep guessing right
because the solutions not good enough
but once this is less than epsilon then
we've reached a good enough solution so
two things to note with approximate
solutions right so you can get more
accurate answers if your step size is
really really small if you're
incrementing by point zero zero zero one
you're going to get a really good
approximate solution but your program
will be a lot slower okay same sort of
idea with epsilon you can change epsilon
if you change epsilon to be a bigger
epsilon right you're sacrificing
accuracy but you're going to reach a
solution a lot faster so here's the code
for the approximate solution of a cube
root might look intimidating but look
almost half this code is just
initializing variables
okay so we're initializing this is a
cube we want to find the cube root of we
pick an epsilon of this we start with a
guess of zero we start with an increment
of point zero zero zero one and just for
fun let's keep track of the number of
guesses that it takes us to get to the
answer this is similar to the guess and
check from before if or it's not so what
this part is similar to I guess and
check from before so if so we're going
to take the guess to the power of three
minus the cube right so that's how far
away are we from the actual answer and
we're going to say if that's not good
enough so if we're still greater than or
equal to the epsilon then keep guessing
so we're going to be stuck in this loop
where we keep guessing values until
we've reached a guess that's good enough
so until we're small we're less than
Epsilon
and the way we keep guessing is just
with this line right here which says
increment by guests by increment my
guests by increment and increment being
this really small value that makes sense
okay so I'm going to keep incrementing
my guests by that small value before I
go on I'm going to run the code and
we're going to discover a small issue
with it okay
so with 27 we're going to run it perfect
it took me 300 guesses but two point
nine nine nine nine nine nine is close
to the cube root of 27 okay we can find
the cube root of this guy here and it
took me twenty thousand guesses but I
figured out that two hundred point nine
nine and a nine so two hundred and one
is close to the cube root of that large
number and then I should have done this
this is going to be a giveaway you guys
sorry then we're going to have let's say
I want to try cube of ten thousand so
ten thousand is not a perfect cube so we
can run the code and with eight one two
oh 601 I had already gotten an answer
but with ten thousand I'm not getting an
answer yet right so I'm I'm thinking
that there might be something wrong so
I'm going to stop my code so I just hit
control C because I feel like I've
entered an infinite loop and in fact I
have so what ended up happening is this
problem here so I'm going to draw
something according to the code
I'm going to start from zero and I'm
going to increment right my guesses like
that with every with every little
increment I'm going to make a new guess
I'm going to take that guess to the
power of three I'm going to subtract the
cube and I'm going to figure out if I'm
less than Epsilon okay this is the
epsilon that I want to be in okay this
little bit here so with every new guess
I might be maybe so this is where I want
to be right within this little boundary
here with every new guess I might be
here with the next guess over here I
might be here when I make another guess
I might be here so I'm getting close to
being with an Epsilon but maybe with my
next guess I'm going to hop over my
epsilon and have made too big of a guess
okay so just because of the way the
numbers right the numbers were chosen in
this example just to illustrate this
using an increment of 0.01 with finding
the cube of 10,000 and epsilon of 0.1 it
turns out that as I'm doing all these
calculations I'm going to skip over this
perfect bound this perfect sort of
epsilon difference so first I'm going to
be too too small and then I'm going to
be too large and once I've become too
large or too far away from Epsilon the
guess is I continue to make are just
going to be even even farther away from
Epsilon and I'm not going to get to my
answer and that's why I've reached an
infinite loop in this code okay all I'm
doing in this code is guessing whether
it is checking whether my guest cube
minus cube is less than Epsilon the only
thing I need to do here is sort of add
this little clause here that says oh by
the way also check that I'm less than
cube because this is just like we did in
the very first program when I'm taking
I'm checking your 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
right when I'm trying to find the cube
root of 8
ah cube root of eight right
once I've reached eight I'm going to
stop and it's the same thing here so I
just added this lo clause that says well
while I'm greater than equal to the
epsilon and I'm still less than the
actual cube just keep searching but once
I've reached the cube then stop
searching and with ten thousand you can
see that I failed to actually find so
that's what I that's what this part here
does it tells me that I've failed to
find the cube root with those particular
parameters okay last thing we're going
to look at is bisection search and to
illustrate this I'm going to need one
volunteer and you're going to play a
game with me in front of the whole class
and there will be a prize
ah there go the hands in the blue shirt
right there all right cool so the prize
is going to be once again this I promise
I don't have I don't have millions of
these Google glasses I also don't work
for Google I just happen to get a couple
okay
so the game is this I'm going to ask
I'm going to ask you to pick a number a
whole number between 0 and 100 okay
and I'm going to try to guess it and you
need to make it hard for me and you make
it so hard for me that I cannot guess it
within 10 guesses okay and if you can do
that if I cannot guess it within 10
guesses you get this okay so and I'm
going to draw out what I do as we go
along
okay so do you have your number yes okay
perfect
let me erase that actually I should
probably kept that because I'll still
use it okay there's the numbers zero to
100 okay is your number 50 okay 50 was
my guess so I've made one guess is is
your number higher lower than 50 higher
okay is your number
my next guest is going to be 75 and the
guest and the reason I'm guessing 75 is
because what's your name
what's that Sophie Sophie said 50 was
too low so I immediately know that it
cannot be any less than 50 so I've
already eliminated half of the numbers
right so my next guest is 75 is your
number 75 okay lower is your number
lower higher higher is your neck okay so
I'm since it's higher I'm eliminating
this half here is your number between 75
and 100 oh boy you're putting me on the
spot what's that 87 thank you 87 higher
or lower lower okay so since it's lower
I'm gonna let me eliminating that half
is your number 81 higher or lower okay
so she said lower so I'm eliminating
that half is your number 78 boy that's
really hard 78 okay higher lower is your
number 76 yay all right perfect
76 was the number so how many guesses
have I made one two three four five six
I made six guesses so I did get it under
under ten but you know what the game was
rigged so you get so you get the prize
anyway just because I pick the game here
you go thank you all right
so notice in bisection search what I did
was I eliminated half the search space
right with every guess I said well she
said it's higher or lower so I
definitely cannot be in the other search
space right if I was doing approximate
solution or in this case guess in check
I would be I would be asking Sophie is
your number zero one two three four and
so on
right so with guess and check it would
have taken me 76 guesses to get to the
number whereas with this bisection
search that I just did it only took me
six right is that cool so that means
that the larger the space actually is
that I need to search the better it is
to use bisection search this bisection
search method okay so that's basically
what I'm illustrating here so we have
our original search space we're going to
choose a guess halfway and eliminate
half of the guesses then we're going to
choose an look in the remaining interval
eliminate half the guesses and so on and
so on
okay so then this is the code for
bisection search also looks intimidating
but it's not so bad
so we're initializing a bunch of stuff
up here most important a couple things
we're initializing our first of all this
high and this low boundaries okay so
with a guessing game the low boundary
was zero and the high boundary was a
hundred right when we're looking at the
cube root the low boundary is going to
be zero right and the high boundary is
going to be just my cube right because
the cubed because I guess to the power
of three cannot be any greater than cube
and then just going to do the same
procedure that I did the guessing game
which is I'm going to make my guess be
halfway in between
so with this guessing game I had to sort
of choose if if there were three numbers
if there are four numbers in between you
know should I go higher or lower but
when we're doing by section by section
search here we don't care about that
we're just going to do floating point
division because we want a we want
decimal numbers okay so I have a lot
lower boundary and a high boundary and
I've figured out my halfway point then I
have this while loop here while loop is
similar to the approximation method
where as long as I'm not as long as I
don't have a guess that's good enough
so this depicted by this greater equal
to Epsilon as long as my guess is not
good enough I'm going to keep guessing
okay that's what this while loop is
saying
so if the guests the power of three -
cube is not good enough keep guessing
and the way I keep guessing is this part
here says my guess was too low so if my
guess was too low set the low boundary
to be the guess right because I don't
care about all of the other numbers that
are much lower than me so set the low to
be the guess that's what that line is
doing and otherwise my guess was too
high that's what this else is doing so
set the high to be the guess because I
don't care about numbers any higher than
my guess okay once I have these new
boundaries I make another guess again
halfway in between the new boundary
points okay so essentially I'm just
having my interval with every single
guess okay and that's what the while
loop is doing and then I print out the
remaining part so notice the search
space right originally being n we're
having it with each guess so the first
guest divides it by two the second gets
divided by four and so on so by the time
we get to the kaif guess and / - k right
the kaif guess let's say that's the
actual answer we're interested in
there's only one value in that little
interval and that's the answer we want
so 2 to the K is equal to n and then how
many guests did we make k is equal to
log base 2 of n so when we were playing
the guessing game of 100 right my n was
100 log base 2 of 100 is 6 point
something I think so in fact I could
have said if I don't guess it within 7
guesses you would have won as well so
that's why the game was rigged right so
the guest notice it converges on the
order of log base n instead of just
linearly in terms of n so that's why
it's so powerful one last thing I want
to mention is the code I showed only
works for positive cubes and that's
because of the following so I have the
zero and one let's say I'm trying to
find the cube root of 0.5 when I first
set my initial boundaries my low is this
one and my high is this one right but
what's the cube root of 0.5 is it within
this boundary or is it outside this
boundary
I heard outside it's like 0.7 something
so it's out here so with this particular
code I'm going to be having my interval
in between those numbers but I'll never
get to an answer because the actual cube
root of 0.5 or numbers less than 1 is
going to be outside that boundary so
there's a small change you can make to
the program which will fix that and
that's in the code I didn't put it in
but it's a very small change a small if
statement so that's it all right thank
you
[Applause]